if you can build a monster company
inside of financial space that gives you
all the resources to build your brand so
it's thinking about I'm doing my
personal brand inside of my business and
that's how I'm going to monetize as
opposed to having to wait and make 3
years of content self-funded and second
guess every expense like do I hire a
videographer or not that much that c me
like I'm not getting enough views where
if you can build a brand inside your
business which a lot of people have
proven that model out like Tom Bill U is
another example he started it he was a
co-founder of quest didn't want to do
the bars anymore and he started uh
inside Quest I don't you ever saw that
show where he brought in people like
Tony Robins and other people and he was
doing this YouTube show interview show
under the quest branding and he loved
doing it and his Partners at Quest are
like dude we sell bars like this it just
doesn't fit right and so he left you
know he has his ownership but he left
the day-to-day of the company to start
impact Theory but without the quest and
the resources it would have been really
really hard for him to start impact
Theory so it became the platform to him
to be able to build and grow
right
we got Mark here part of the Mastermind
uh it's part of that we're doing a
one-on-one so what's on your mind man
how can I help well um super happy to be
here and I'm really just looking for I
guess Clarity
Direction I really want to help people
overcome the things I've overcome you
know uh anxiety depression um I've got a
story that's led me to here been on this
planet over 50 years and just in the
last couple of years that's where a lot
of things have sort of evolved if you
will and I've over been able to overcome
some pretty major
obstacles and I feel like that you know
at this point I'm ready to share that
with the world and uh make a business
out of it so we've talked before about
you know you being in the mortgage
business
and having this new angle that you want
to be able to
share and is it okay to have it on the
same channel and the same right and and
I definitely does CU a lot of people in
that space struggle with all the things
that you struggled with how quickly do
we need to monetize this new brand
because it's obvious something much
bigger than just mortgage eventually
right you want to you want to serve the
world so quickly I've been patient this
whole time I feel like when I arrived
here this is the first day of the rest
of my life just walking into this room
um I feel like God brought me to this
place uh not just physically but brought
me to this place in life you know I'm
ready to do whatever it takes to you
know if I could align you know this
whole thing of like if I could align the
things that that make me really excited
and that's helping people and and also
oh gosh you get to make money with that
I would feel like a pro football player
I mean I just would feel like you know
but yet so this is the rest of my life
you know you know I want to do this the
rest of my life um people are always
going to call me for financial and real
estate advice you know how to how to how
to build a portfolio
because because I've been doing it for
so long 27 years so I'm not in a hurry
you know but I would like to do it as
quickly as you know as the as Yoda can
can make me help me do
it I love I I'm at your service I love
it I'm a young Jedi how do you make the
most money right now in the mortgage
business in the financial business is it
you dealing with higher net worth people
and closing bigger deals or is it you
recruiting team underneath you to do the
deals great question um I literally just
segwayed from the retail space which
means I was sort of a captive it's funny
I used to work for RBC mortgage back in
the day so this logo out here okay they
had a branch in Tennessee many years ago
and uh but I've been with a company sort
of captive was unable to grow and but
you know my and then I wanted to segue
over to the broker channel the broker
world so I'm able to sort of have more
autonomy and I'm able to grow a team
underneath me so i' I've did this within
the last three weeks and I've already
have a recruit that's signed on so
things are moving quickly um but I'd
like to build out you know a team of
people I monetize that but to answer
your question certainly the bigger the
loan typically the bigger the commission
so I make really my money comes from um
closing loans that are home loans um but
also uh I work with Builders uh house
flippers that sort of thing that help
them with Fix and Flip loans and
groundup construction so that was the
other tools in my tool belt that I
didn't really have I was sort of only
helping you know like he Markham wants
to do he wants to refinance their home
or they want to buy another home in
Marco Island hey I can help you with
that however I couldn't help really the
builders Bankers that sort of thing so
now I've got all those tools in my tool
belt um so plugged into a complete
broker plat platform so I'm I'm
operating a new business within a
business so I went from W2 to
1099 uh brought my partner on with me
and uh and I've already hired a new
recruit and uh so he's on board that's
how I make a living dayto day who's your
favorite athlete of all time Deion
Sanders why because he he did what he
said he's gonna do because he says it
and then he does it and this just
confirmed it more that is either him or
Muhammad Ali but right now you ask me in
this season right now it was pretty much
Muhammad Jordan Bo and Dion that was it
for me right there so Muhammad Ali was
really in M Michael were the all times I
mean I have shares with Muhammad Ali
Schwarz with him I loved him you know I
saw him fight on ABC you know Howard
coell and n i mean I just loved The
Bravery that he had to do what he did
you know back in the 60s to give
everything up in the name of you know
what he believed in so what's
interesting here is is obviously you
pick some winners right you're going to
Ali Jordan Sanders was he a winner you
know he's definitely what he's doing now
in his pro career I don't know how much
he won I'm more of the baseball side of
things but you wouldn't consider Sanders
to be like one of the greatest uh
baseball players of all time I don't
know how you rank him in the football
world but he's probably not top top not
in baseball he was a freak in baseball I
mean you see more of the stuff coming
out now but football he won a couple
Super Bowls but you went to the number
one basketball and the number one of
boxing for sure you didn't go to the
number one of football no I didn't but
what's interesting is like if you look
at why it's not just because they won
but it's what they stood for it's their
story and that might seem like a random
question like you're talking work ises
why you asking me about this because I
think I see the same thing in
you in the ability to both recruit team
and recruit
clients based not just off the
performance but the story so in your
willingness to share what you've been
through and the mission that you're on I
think it actually attracts the right
people to you both clients and team
which then that can parlay into
something much bigger if you look at you
know Ed mlet came from the financial
World Patrick bavid came from the
financial world now doing things outside
the financial World in a big way follow
them daily yeah that's their background
and still you know kind heavy ties to
the business but you they don't talk
much about it you don't hear Ed and
Patrick talking about that business too
much a little bit but if you were to see
their show you wouldn't think oh this is
the yeah insurance guy right right but
it becomes a a vehicle to get to the
next step you know if
you took the same courage that you talk
about Ali and Sanders in and bring that
to your business and your content and
your messaging like upfront it's not
just that you're a winner and you can
help them get the deal it's also the
story behind it why would I pick you
over somebody else you have the track
record but other people have the track
record you know is your track record
that much better than somebody else's
you
know maybe compared to Startup for sure
but there's other people who have more
experience than you do but they don't
have your
story and that combination is where you
start to bring on the right people I
love it that may not be the final
destination right right because what you
talk about with anxiety and depression
is is I mean you know the numbers better
than I do across the US and how
devastating it is for people so you have
the ability to jump it into something
much much much
bigger and the platform that helps you
build that is inside your business so
it's great that you already made that
step because you know I didn't know
where you were at if you said the only
way I can grow my business is if I bring
on bigger deals you know okay so let's
use our brand to bring our B good deals
now that you know you took that step
that you can have Team underneath you
well who are the best people are going
to work for you the ones who value you
and your message and your
mentorship not just they could be a high
performer yeah somebody who struggled
with May or is struggling with
depression and anxiety because you could
be a high performer and have massive
anxiety and
depression
yeah right I mean it's not as people at
home unemployed like you could be
massive High performer and really strugg
but those will be the people who who
you'll love the most like personally
love the most get the most fulfillment
from seeing them grow showing them that
there's hope that they don't have to go
down this really negative path I mean I
don't know what the worst case scenario
was for you in your story of how how bad
it got or almost got but knowing that
your story your message could help
somebody not go down that same path and
get out sooner because in you they see
hope and somebody who turned their life
around I think at this point in my
career I'm just I'm not
necessarily um you can only talk about
mortgages for so many decades until you
get sort of like where you get where you
want to you want to help people and
that's the part I like right you know
but getting into the weeds of um the
details I for rather have my team do
that you know hey what rate this that
and the other what program you know
that's where I think if if I could
figure out a way to
monetize where you know I'm actually
helping people you know on a
platform with helping them with whether
it be I mean I was there was it was a
cannabis addiction that was pretty
serious one just within the last couple
of years that reared its head again and
during coid I've overcome that I mean if
somebody is heavily addicted to cannabis
I can show them what it takes to get
through that and over that and it's
everywhere now I mean I've been in
Brooklyn and and uh LA and South Florida
in the last 3 weeks and you just walk
around in cwh and there's no judgment
for me whatsoever I just know that I
know that feeling of thinking that
you're you this this is not the right
this is not helping me really you know
and and then the anxiety is a you know a
a huge thing that can just feel like
this weight you're carrying around
um almost like this you know 300 lb dude
or Monster or thing in the car with you
yeah sometimes we're just wired this way
but I think the the whole thing is to
get to the root of it and that's what
I've been able to do like get really
down to the root like what happened you
dealing with trauma you know finding out
asking questions from family members and
you know your parents your aunts your
uncles and what did you see in me why
was I bully in first grade you know why
is it anger still coming come out now
sometimes I want to I want
to fix that I want to be better I want
to be you know more open to be able to
be a vessel that God uses me to pour
into other people so your story and your
message can impact the world that's a
process it's a process of building a
brand getting known getting better at
the storytelling more practice putting
in the Reps creating the content Etc
right that's that's the process and that
leads to amazing things that leads to
Brand deals it leads to speaking gigs it
leads to Keynotes it leads to
sponsorships it leads to people asking
to join their board of directors that
leads to all sorts of magical potential
things on the back of you having your
brand as being known as the guy who
talks about
blank the monetization in the meantime
comes from inside your business you know
how to grow your business but an even
better way to do it is to bring in the
story so you practice it it and bringing
in the right people where a lot of times
people would say well that I don't want
I can't I can't tell people like I have
anxiety or I was depressed or was on
cannabis or like addicted to anything uh
and some people might see that as a
negative but those people probably
wouldn't be great clients for you anyway
you know it's just it's truly
transactional yeah well for other people
that's the reason why they want to sign
up with you yeah like I'm giving the
deal to mark because of this it's
interesting you say that because I
created a PowerPoint recently just
Within last couple of weeks and went and
shared
this you know in the last four pages
were all
about Bridge loans fix and flips just
you know ground of construction but the
first two pages were really a my post
for my 55th birthday where I'm standing
with my shirt off and saying 55 is not
so bad this is two weeks ago and we were
in um Marina del re and just explaining
you know hey this is where I'm at this
is what I've overcome the last last
couple years I want to share something
with you and listed about 20 thing 15 or
20 things that I've done differently it
was it came down to decisions that I
made it was no one thing you know so I
think sometimes people think it's one
thing but my point with that was here's
this presentation to your point and this
is the first two pages have nothing to
do you know with mortgages and I just I
was just vulnerable and just put it out
there and um you know hey this is kind
of what I who I am you here's who you
here's who's talking to you kind of
thing is the way I I I saw that I did a
printed version as well because I was
going around visiting some bankers and
Builders and whatnot and you know they
they ask questions about it and then
people ask afterwards like hey how did
you tell me about that like I struggle
like with my relationships like really
going deeper with my wife my family my
children what did you do you know
so it was there just within the last you
know 10 days two weeks that I realized
that okay this is people are connecting
you
know now how we go from there to hey
they pay for something that I provide
you know I see people that have you know
Huber and these different you know Dr
Nick they have these supplements and all
these things and so I don't know I don't
know what that that's that's where I
think you come in you know so many
opportunities open up for an Andrew hman
or whoever right it's getting the brand
to be that size the the best part for
you was I mean Andrew had a he's a he's
a professor so he had his job and he
just started teaching and making content
a lot of his stuff is he just sits in
front of a camera with his papers for
three hours and just starts talking
about all the things are on his way and
people watch because it's interesting
and they they find Value in it but you
have a business
that if I'm you I'd be looking
at 50% of my content my speeches my
talks my everything you're doing inside
your business connects to your story
somehow so every slide deck you do has
an element of the story whether it's 55
and look at how good I am or whether
it's 32 and at your lowest moment or
like whatever whatever those key moments
are because that's what this a
relationship business so you're you're
creating bonds with people so what are
people going to buy well at the
beginning what they're going to buy is
mortgages and they're gonna they're
going to buy you and want to join your
team those are the two things we're
selling right like either big loans
bigger and bigger loans or I want to
join your team instead of somebody
else's team because you get me where
it's not just about the kpis and
learning the business but like I care
about you as a human and if you're
struggling with some of these things why
might be able to help I like that but
until you store obviously people don't
know that picture uh Alex sent me too
Alex on my team sales guy Alex he's like
look at my boy Mark and he circulated
that around because you posted on
Instagram too it wasn't just in your
PowerPoint I did it not of a real but it
was in my story but um I'm not sure if I
post on Instagram or not actually
but you know what 55 you have a lot of
friends that are still on Facebook right
when you're when you know some people
never gravitate over I mean I didn't
have an instag
handle until 18 months ago I grew it
organically 55 53,000 whatever it is now
and um yeah it's interesting
that you know the content creation what
people connect with and what they don't
you know but yeah I'm I'm I'm really
interested
in melding those two together like
you're saying you know like what that
looks like and so I'm just
marching
forward knowing that I don't know the
answers now yeah you know I've I've
dumped out of the plane if you will and
learning going to learn to fly yeah and
I know I will it's a two to five year
plan and then ultimately you use your
story to be the frontman for your
company which then is either just
throwing off so much cash flow that then
you go do something else or you you sell
it to somebody else who takes over and
now you are the guy who's
about anxiety and depression and
addiction and you just happen to come
from the mortgage business like people
won't even know that you come from the
mortgage business just like Patrick and
yeah and Ed Ed where that was their
whole thing at the beginning yeah I mean
Ed I mean I got to meet him last year
you know he gave me a big hug and I'm
there for he man you're buff I like you
guys and what was so interesting about
that is when I looked back on that I was
I weighed 209 and I I felt so out of
shape and just not in a good place this
was last maybe June July something like
that this was in Vegas at Neil ding's um
event the forward event you know I went
home and I saw the picture and I was
just like
man yeah he was just trim and fit and
you know he's a little shorter than me
and but like I knew I needed to make
changes and that really sort of
propelled me but it was just it's
interesting when you know he I I really
connect with him so much he's such a
great Storyteller right um you are as
well and it's just I loved hearing him
talk you know and just connecting with
the pain and the Really overcoming and I
could see myself doing and talking just
from the heart like he does you know
yeah 100% and now he's at the point
where you don't know that he's from the
financial space he never never talks
about it and his content like Patrick
still brings up Insurance every now and
then but Ed doesn't talk about it at all
not that he's ashamed of anything he's
just he's grown Beyond it having to be
what he does dayto day and so it's that
it becomes an evolution where like if
you made the conscious choice that okay
starting from today 50% of the things I
talk about is going to be related to
addiction and anxiety and overcoming and
50% is going to be about the the tactics
and the actual business but but every
presentation every training session like
when somebody on your team comes in for
their performance review it's not just
their numbers performance review yeah
it's like how you feeling right how's
the anxiety level for you right now
that's not normal in a performance
review right but it is for your
organization so like half of what you do
is is the the X's and O's and half is
this stuff and you use that as a
catalyst to grow an explosive company in
a new way yeah and then over with time
that's gonna going to be 60% and 70% 80%
then if you want it becomes 100% And
like we barely know that you're in oh
yeah he was the mortgage guy like five
years ago right right I I think you know
and I'm impatient you know I'm working
on that this is the path right like
because if you if you can build a
monster company inside of financial
space that gives you all the resources
to build your brand right so it's
thinking about I'm doing I'm doing my
personal brand inside of my business and
that's how I'm going to monetized as
opposed to having to wait and make three
years of content
self-funded and second guess every
expense like do I hire a videographer or
not how much does that cost me like I'm
not getting enough views where if you
can build the brand inside your business
which a lot of people have proven that
model out like Tom Bill U is another
example he started it he was a
co-founder of quest didn't want to do
the bars anymore and he started uh
inside Quest I don't ever saw that show
or not but he his first YouTube channel
was was was called inside Quest where he
brought in people like Tony Robins and
other people and he was doing this
YouTube show interview show under the
quest branding and he loved doing it and
his Partners at Quest are like dude we
sell bars like what this it just doesn't
fit right and so he left you know he has
his ownership but he left the day-to-day
of the company to start impact Theory
but without the quest and the resources
it would have been really really hard
for him to start impacting Theory so it
became the platform to him to be able to
build and grow right same thing for
Patrick when I went to his
studio uh in Dallas before he moved to
Florida he was in Texas and he spent a
million bucks on his Studio like at the
start I went to see him when he was like
just on the on the come
up a million bucks how do you just drop
a million dollars on a YouTube studio
and hope that it's going to turn out
well because he had a super successful
business to help fund it right if if
you're impatient amazing I am too right
it's great like that becomes a path use
your story to build your business which
then throws off cash to continue to
invest into you building the brain which
then continue to help build your
business yeah because if people then how
however long you want to stay in the
financial space and maybe it's for the
rest of your life it could just be a
vehicle to give opportunity where if
people find you for your brand and they
say I I I'm I'm a high performer I have
all this anxiety and I don't know what
to do I don't know you could help them
with their life
but you can also recruit them to then
join your organization too like hey
here's a better Financial opportunity
for you as well if you're interested
yeah I think some years
ago you know the statistics were that a
mortgage Banker was the second highest
stress related job next to an air
traffic control person I don't know if
this if you know these rankings or
whatever if it's the same now but it was
clearly up there at one point and so now
I believe it you know and the same thing
and maybe now more than ever yeah just
because of the market contractions just
so much I mean I'm aware what's going on
here in Canada it's you know as bad as
as bad as it is um struggling for
Millennials and gen Z folks to buy home
and in the US I mean I hear my Canadian
friends you know it's I hear it loud and
clear it's hard and I have a heart for
that I mean it's it is tough I think to
your point you know to those people that
are struggling you know with
anxiety they don't know how to deal with
it you
know in the business side I have been
brought to a better platform you know
there's there's more money to be made
there's there's you have better options
for people um you have more control over
pricing for rates because I'm a broker
now I can you know plug it plug it in
and you know 100 I you know basically
you're shopping 150 blenders immediately
and it does the shopping for them they
don't have have to go around and shop
around and put an application all over
town so all those things you know sort
of
align and um with what I'm with what I'm
you know wanting to do yeah well now
imagine you have a 100 high performers
underneath you selling these mortgages
who love
you as a human not just love the
business because working with you
changed their life like the impact that
has on them as humans and brings back to
their families literally saving lives
and the lives of their
families as well as being very
profitable to give you the platform to
go and change the world with your
content yeah that's the impatient way to
do it because it gives you the finances
to go off and build the Beast that makes
sense and I think I need my my goal
needs to be bigger I mean I'm just been
thinking like gosh if I could hire 10 to
20 L's underneath me in addition to this
new you know my new guy
man what an what a impact that would be
even if they're only closing a couple
loans two three loans a month that would
be huge so to have a 100 I mean that's
definitely
possible yeah it's 100% possible so yeah
I'm
excited
um you know it's a healthy fear now I
guess you say I mean and I guess back to
you know to
Dion I can't imagine
losing two of my toes you know and and
the prospect of losing my foot is
because of the bad circulation thing
he's got you know and his attitude about
it is just he's he feels
called you know it's a calling for him
you know all the people I mentioned
they're all sort of cocky I guess you
know Muhammad I mean they there's a lot
of talk but I also think about that
comes from their experience you know
their own personal experience you know
um is African-Americans growing up and
what they went through
and I think part of me always was
envious of that struggle in a sense or
you know
because I felt like I didn't I knew that
they it it gave them an edge in their
mind like that kept them focused like
because they had to you know they're
going to succeed if he was going to
succeed man he's he's going to be dialed
in and you're just you're not going to
stop me well listen you definitely had a
lot of struggles to get to where you are
now so uh I think a lot of people
will look at your story and when we ask
them you know who is your hero they're
gonna say Mark instead of Deion
Sanders i' love
that let's go let's go Mark Ney much
love man man nice love thank you so much
to watch me coach another Mastermind
member oneon-one check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there some people criticize us for doing
what we're doing like you guys are nuts
to start a business at your age why aren
you enjoying life well I'm enjoying life
now more than I ever have that's what
some people don't get